fire and flow festivals have been an
integral part of flow arts culture for
nearly two decades but in the past five
years they've also by and large fallen
on some hard times why is that and what
does it mean for the first festival
season in two years that's the topic of
today's video drex here from drexfactor
poi sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today i'm diving into
the triumph and tragedy of the flow
festivals and how the culture around
them has changed over the years before
we dive in i just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard lane machinski and
becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission so first up i
should probably clarify what i'm talking
about when i say flow or fire festival
flow or fire festivals are weekend-long
events that cater specifically to flow
and fire artists frequently though not
always they involve camping out in rural
locations for a weekend to be immersed
in flow culture with workshops during
the day and nighttime spin jams or fire
circles for attendees while there are
scores of precedence for flow events
including circus or juggling festivals
burning man and satellite regional burns
conventions and music festivals the
first true fire festival fire drums was
first held in 2004 and i think it's
important to really recognize this
moment for what it was in the history of
flow arts and flow arts culture
where before fire spending was seen as
kind of a niche within circus rave or
burner communities the founding of an
event designed specifically to cater to
fire artists signaled both a critical
mass of enthusiasts for them as well as
a culture that was distinct enough to
warrant its own unique events the first
fire drums was pretty low-key with most
workshops being informal events that
were staged on an ad-hoc basis in the
following years fire drums formalized
the structure of the event inviting
teachers from all over the world to
teach daytime workshops while inviting
popular djs to play for the fire circle
at night the formula was a massive
success one of the early attendees to
fire drums was a new england-based
entrepreneur named chad bennett who
created his own spin on the format by
founding wildfire in connecticut for
many years fire drums and wildfire were
kind of the yin and yang of fire
festivals with fire drums cultivating a
competitive party-like atmosphere that
attracted top-tier talent from across
the world and wildfire retaining a much
more casual atmosphere centered around
education and shared experiences and for
several years these two events were the
only two in the united states that
catered specifically to flow artists but
the founding of the festivals also
coincided with a major social and
cultural change that had an impact not
just on the wider world but also became
a catalyst for the growth of the flow
arts the introduction of youtube and
social media for most of the history of
the fire arts the only way to be exposed
to it or learn the basics was to
encounter another person who engaged in
it but social media changed all that by
making information more accessible than
ever the sharing of video in particular
lowered the barriers to entry for people
to be exposed to and learn about fire
spinning and with that interest in the
flow arts exploded coming into the late
2000s demand began to swell for these
flow events and both fire drums and
wildfire began to sell out regularly the
fire drums team worked to franchise its
model under the umbrella of a company
known first as axis mundi and later as
flow arts institute or fai
realizing that many of their attendees
were traveling great distances to take
part in the event they sought to add
more events throughout the country to
meet the demand and give people events
closer to home to attend wildfire on the
other hand added multiple events per
year as overflow for the demand peaking
out at four events per year at the same
venue even then each individual event
frequently sold out people innovated on
the model flow fest a company based in
florida hosts multiple flow events a
year but rather than having attendees
camp out for them they're all located in
major cities not only does it make the
events more accessible but it also aids
in the discovery of flow arts by placing
them in highly visible spaces and scores
of independent events began to pop up
all across the country sometimes with
multiple events in the same region or
even just miles away from each other
having been very active in the scene at
the time i can tell you that this was an
incredibly exciting time there was a
point at which i was spending roughly
half the year on the road touring and
traveling between events the peak of
this explosive growth happened between
2013 and 2015. in 2013 fire drums had
its highest ever attendance at well over
a thousand people and in 2015 there were
more than 50 events hosted in the united
states alone for me the moment that
finally brought home not just how much
the scene had grown but how distinct and
unique it had become was when wildfire
added a third yearly event the week of
burning man
having come into the fire and flow arts
from the burner community it was
incomprehensible to me that there could
be enough people sitting out the burn to
make the event worth hosting
and then to my great shock the event
sold out it was a huge wake-up call to
me that flow culture had truly come into
its own but what made these events so
popular for attendees there was this
incredible feeling of belonging being a
flow artist frequently meant that you
felt like a bit of an outsider wherever
you happened to live
being able to connect with people that
shared your interests and nurtured a
feeling of belonging has been incredibly
important to all subcultures and for
flow artists that sense of belonging was
super addictive the festivals also
fostered symbiotic relationships with
many elements of the emerging culture as
tech poi culture emerged among math
curious sectors of the poi community the
festivals provided not only a place to
interact with and compare notes with
other innovators but also an eager
audience to teach all these new
techniques to for the many companies
that sprung up to build props for the
emerging scene festivals also provided a
venue to get direct and hands-on
feedback from potential customers to say
nothing of the opportunity to develop
more direct relationships with people
who could inspire others in their home
communities to want to pick up those
same props for many the festivals also
scratched an itch for travel you could
pop around the country checking out a
variety of different cities scenes and
see parts of the country in between and
on the business side of things the flow
festival's presented an easy model to
copy in a variety of different locations
it wasn't difficult for an attendee to
one event to pick up enough information
to host their own event closer to home
for a lot of people who felt bored or
uncreative in their traditional jobs the
festivals represented an opportunity to
be seen or to become part of something
bigger organizers felt the pull of being
part of a team and instructors quickly
became rock stars people who'd never
felt important talented or beautiful
before suddenly had a stage to get on
and feel good about themselves but the
explosive growth was not to last and it
became clear pretty quickly that a lot
of what led to it was unsustainable one
of the first signs of this was that the
smaller independent festivals began
failing on mass we went from 50
festivals in 2015 to only 20 in 2017
and what was even more troubling was
that this didn't result in greater
ticket sales at other events during this
period i worked for flame festival near
atlanta georgia and we saw the event
grow by 15 to 20 percent per year for
three years
and then the growth just stopped
the event plateaued at around 500
attendees and then declined slightly in
the last year that i worked there and it
wasn't the only one wildfire events
stopped selling out and for the first
time the organizers had to cancel their
fall event when ticket sales didn't
reach the threshold necessary to host
the event
the cancellation sent shock waves
through the new england community and
resulted in the organizers scaling back
the number of events that they hosted in
future years i talked to organizers at
other events and they told me similar
stories attendance began to drop or
plateau after 2015. demand had dried up
and suddenly even more established
events were struggling to stay
profitable and competitive so what went
wrong first up let's talk economics one
of my first clues that things were about
to take a turn with the fire festivals
was that i noticed wherever i'd go that
i'd see the same 20 or 30 people at
every single event you attended
and i'm not just talking about teachers
either i'm talking about attendees
touring through the scene like they were
deadheads following their favorite bands
ticket sales were being inflated by
devotees so when these people were no
longer able to afford to spend the time
or money to travel this much
many festivals found that they were no
longer profitable without them
basically the flow festivals were a
bubble
and that bubble burst it also didn't
help that many of the people starting
new events had never run a business
before the logistics marketing and
infrastructure requirements for doing so
all turned out to be way more
challenging than many festival hosts
were prepared for
i know multiple people who took
multi-thousand dollar losses attempting
to create their own events in addition
to people being inexperienced running
businesses many of the people staffing
the events were untrained in their roles
and ill-prepared to handle events that
grew beyond a few hundred people
this meant high staff turnovers and
events that were being run in a costly
and inefficient manner it also has to be
said that the festivals encountered a
lot of cultural problems too one of the
biggest points of contention has to be
the compensation of instructors when the
model was originally created the pool of
instructors was largely undifferentiated
and nearly all of them could subsidize
volunteering for a weekend
this meant that there was no incentive
to give those instructors much
compensation beyond a stipend to cover
their travel if that but the rise in
social media in addition to making the
discovery of the flow arts easier also
created incentive structures for people
to get super specialized and virtuosic
in their work many were constantly
volunteering their time outside of the
festivals and struggling to find income
streams to support their work
so it just didn't really seem fair for
the festivals to be selling tickets off
their names and not compensating them
for it many talented instructors ceased
teaching at or attending the festivals
at all remember how i said that a big
part of what made these events popular
in the first place was that they made
people feel seen
that also became a problem over time too
events were flooded with applications to
teach perform dj or organize by a legion
of people who only needed to be
compensated by feeling special or being
seen
it became real easy to stop booking
costly high-level talent and populate
workshop schedules with inexperienced
teachers galas with mediocre performers
and music lineups with amateur musicians
not only did the quality of offerings at
many events decline heavily but the
dynamic shifted such that it became the
attendees job to serve the instructors
and performers rather than the other way
around and 2013 was an inflection year
for the flow arts world it was the year
that the european juggling convention
was held in toulouse and threepoy became
a hit in the united states catapulting
the american circus craze of the 2010s
many tech poi enthusiasts switched over
to juggling and began demanding events
that had large indoor spaces to train in
which most festivals being held in
isolated rural venues were unable to
provide it also has to be said the
culture around flow arts turned out to
be a perfect storm for harmful behavior
at these events too
you have a primary audience of people
wanting to be seen and willing to be
vulnerable to people that they've never
met
plus an infrastructure that's built by
an untrained labor force that's likely
to be conflict avoidant
it's become clear over the years that
assaults abuse and harassment were a lot
more common at these events than we
thought and after all that covid19 hit
and resulted in all events being
cancelled for a solid two years
in addition to putting an enormous
financial burden on even the events that
were still able to hold on before the
pandemic
it became clear through discourse online
that there were two other enormous
cultural problems the festivals were
facing for one many flow artists of
color came forward to address the lack
of representation in positions of
visibility in the community among them
slots in teaching lineups and organizer
positions
these pleas have frequently resulted in
highly contentious if not outright
hostile pushback
and a lot of flow artists of all races
and backgrounds have seen this as a
signal that the festivals are not safe
spaces in addition we discovered during
the lockdown that there was an enormous
contingent in the fire and flow
communities that were anti-vaccination
and or anti-masking and this has made a
lot of people nervous about attending
events with other people that might be a
threat to their health there is a lot of
anxiety around harmful behavior in the
flow arts community and people factor
that in when they think about whether or
not they'll attend a weekend-long
in-person event in a secluded locale and
all that said there have been notable
outliers that have had success even as
attendance has declined at other events
playthink quasar and equilibrium have
all leaned heavily into becoming as much
music festivals as they are flow events
and they've had good attendance to show
for it and of course it has to be said
that things look a lot different outside
of the united states with fire festivals
pulling in large stadium-like audiences
in eastern europe and retreats in exotic
locales specializing in flow artists
that have the travel bug but as it
stands right now jumping into the 2022
season the future is a little hazy when
it comes to the flow and fire festivals
but is there a way to turn that trend
around to revitalize the festivals and
bring people back to them honestly i
believe that there are some improvements
that could be made and i'll be covering
them in a video next week did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to keep the conversation going and to
help my channel grow this video would
not be possible if not for the wonderful
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible thank you
one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
bodies and their brains so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that either at the link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you're watching on youtube there
you can get access to a whole host of
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
are you planning on attending a flow
festival this year why or why not leave
me a comment and let me know in the
meantime i'll leave a link to a playlist
of other videos i've done on flow
festivals down in the description or up
on screen if you're watching this video
on youtube make sure to get out and flow
today thanks for watching and i'll see
you with a new video on wednesday
peace